website security principles have had a
thorough overhaul over the past few
years this is primarily due to the ease
of access to malicious tools
starting from ddos attacks to remote
code execution
a full-fledged web application security
platform will need to check the major
culprits like cross-site scripting
one of the riskiest attacks to perform
with similar level of rewards when
conducted properly
while the attacks from the client side
on most occasion they can be configured
to work remotely against most secured
platforms as well
let us go through some of the topics to
be covered in today's video on
cross-site scripting
we start by learning the basics of
cross-site scripting and the formative
arguments that go into play when
conducting this attack
next we take a look at ways a cross-site
scripting attack starts and how the
hacker leverages vulnerable web
applications and systems to infect users
and servers alike
moving on we read about the three
distinct categories of attacks when it
comes to cross-site scripting
we then go through some of the industry
recommended measures to prevent systems
from falling prey to cross-site
scripting attacks
and finally we complete a set of
cross-scripting challenges highlighting
the ways hackers think and how a simple
line of code can open up vulnerabilities
if not configured correctly
let's start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a layman's perspective
cross-site scripting also known as xss
is a type of code injection attack that
occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application
the web page or application serves as a
vehicle for the malicious script to be
sent to the user's browser
forum's message boards and online pages
that enable comments are vulnerable
vehicles that are frequently utilized
for cross-scripting assaults
a web page or web application is
vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then parse
this user input
in vbscript activex flash and even css
cross-site scripting attacks are
conceivable
they are nevertheless most ubiquitous in
javascript going to the fact that
javascript is most important to most
browser experiences nowadays
the main purpose of this attack is to
steal the other user's identity be it
via cookies
session tokens and other information
in most of the cases this attack is
being used to steal the other person's
cookies
as we know cookies help us to log in
automatically
therefore with the stolen cookies we can
log in with other identities and this is
one of the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks
it can be performed with different
client-side programming languages as
well
cross-site scripting is often compared
with similar client-set attacks as
client-side languages are mostly being
used during this
however an xss attack is considered
riskier because of its ability to damage
even less vulnerable technologies
most often this attack is performed with
javascript and html javascript is a
programming language that runs on web
pages inside your browser
the client-side code adds functionality
and interactivity to the web page and is
used extensively on all major
applications and cms platforms unlike
server-side languages such as php
javascript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window
while javascript is client-side and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests
attackers can then use these background
requests to add unwanted spam content to
a web page without refreshing it
they can then gather analytics about the
client's browser or perform actions
asynchronously
the manner of attack can range in a
variety of ways it can be a single link
which the user must click on to initiate
a javascript piece of code it can be
used to show any piece of images that
can be later used as a front-end for
malicious code being installed as
malware
but the majority of internet users
unaware of how metadata works are the
ways in which web requests are called
the chances of victims clicking on a
redirecting links is far too high
cross-site scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the client
side using a fake page or even a form
that is displayed to the user
on websites with displayed
advertisements malicious emails can also
be sent to the victim
these attacks occur when the malicious
user finds the vulnerable parts of the
website and sends it as appropriate
malicious input
now that we understand the basics of
cross-site scripting
let us learn more about how this kind of
attack works
the first place we have the website or
the web browser which is used to show
content to the victim or which is the
user in our case
whenever the user wants to grab some
content from the website the website
asks the data from the server the server
provides this information to the website
and the web browser which ultimately
releases the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here
it passes on certain arguments to the
web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways
depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser or stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output
a malicious user can enter a script
which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not
therefore this malicious script is being
executed on the victim's browser or any
faked form if that is being displayed
for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack
for example the execution could be
triggered automatically when the page
loads or when a user hovers over
specific elements of the page like
hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross
cross-site scripting attacks include
capturing keystrokes of a user
redirecting a user to malicious websites
running web browser-based exploits
obtaining cookie information of a user
who is logged into a website and many
more
in some cases cross-site scripting
attack leads to complete compromise of
the victim's account attackers can trick
users into entering credentials on a
fake form which can then provide all
information to the attacker
with the basic working of a cross-site
scripting attack out of the way let us
go over the different ways hackers can
leverage vulnerable web applications to
gather information and eventually breach
those systems
the prime purpose of performing xss
attack is to steal the other person's
identity
as mentioned it may be cookies session
tokens etc
xss may also be used to display fake
pages or forms for the victim however
this can be performed in several ways
we have a reflected attack this attack
occurs when a malicious script is not
being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently
in this case the malicious code is being
reflected in any website result
the attack code can be included in the
faked url or in the http parameters
it can affect the victim in different
ways by displaying fake malicious speech
or by sending a malicious email
in a reflected cross-site scripting
example the input of a search form is
reflected on the page to show what the
search key was an attacker may craft a
url that contains malicious code and
then spread the same url via email or
social media
a user who clicks on this link opens the
valid web application which then runs
the malicious code in the browser
this script is not stored in the web
application and malicious code is shown
only to one user the user that opens the
link executes the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app owner itself
the next variant is a stored cross site
scripting attacks
this occurs when a malicious script is
being saved on the web server
permanently
this can be considered a riskier attack
since it has leverage for more damage
in this type of attack the malicious
code or script is being saved on the
server for example in the database of
the website it is executed every time
the users call the appropriate
functionality
this way stored xss attack can affect
many users
also as the script is being stored on
the web server it will affect the
website for a longer time
in order to perform stored xss attack
the malicious scripts should be sent
through the vulnerable input form for
example can be a comment field or review
field
this way the appropriate script will be
saved in the database and evaluated on
the page load or appropriate function
calling
in a stored xss example the script might
have been submitted by an input field to
the web server which did not perform a
sufficient validation and stores the
script permanently in the database
the consequence of this might be that
the script is now being delivered to all
users visiting the web application and
if for example able to gain access to
the user session cookies
in this attack the script is permanently
stored in the web app the users visiting
the app after the information retrieved
the script
the malicious code then exploits the
flaws in the web application and the
script and the attack is visible on the
server side or to the app owner as well
the third variant is dom-based
cross-site scripting attacks
this type of attack occurs when the dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change
when the dom environment is being
modified in the victim's browser the
client-side code executes differently
in order to get a better understanding
of how xss dom attack is being performed
let us analyze the following example
if there is a website called texting.com
we know default is a parameter
therefore in order to perform axis's dom
attack we should send a script as
parameters
a dom-based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
javascript executed in the browser for
example if the client-side javascript
modifies the dom tree of the web page
it can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be executed
the malicious code the exploits flaws in
the browser on the user side and the
script and the attack is not necessarily
visible on the server side or to the app
owner
by now it is clear that cross-site
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of ways one can
safeguard against such attacks
let's go through some of these
preventive measures
like mentioned earlier
excesses attacks are sometimes difficult
to detect
however this can be changed if you get
some external help
a way to prevent excess attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or acunetix security suit
still manual testing is highly time
consuming and costly and therefore not
possible to be done for every iteration
of your web application
consequently your code shouldn't be
untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-site
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
applications live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature
input fields are the most common point
of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields
this is particularly important if the
data will be included as html output
this can be used to protect against
reflected xss attacks
validation should occur on both the
client side and server side as an added
precaution
this helps validating the data before
it's being sent to the servers and can
also protect against persistent xss
scripts
this can be accomplished using
javascript
xss attacks only appear if any user
input is being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible
if you need to display user data
restrict the places where the user input
might appear
any input displayed inside a javascript
tag or a url shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the html body
protecting against excess
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page
rather than trying to determine if the
data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and escape data whether it is user
provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final code
encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you are
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use
for example values inside a javascript
string require a different type of
escaping to those in an html context
sometimes you'll need to apply multiple
layers of encoding in the correct order
for example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both javascript context and the
html context so you need to first
unicode escape the input and then html
encoded
content security policy or csp is a
computer security standard introduced to
prevent cross-site scripting click
checking and other code injection
attacks resulting from the execution of
malicious content in the trusted web
page context
it is a candidate recommendations of the
w3c working group on web application
security
it's widely supported by modern web
browsers and provides a standard method
for website owners to declare approved
origins of content that browser should
be allowed to load on that website
http only is an additional flag included
in a set cookie http response header
using the http only flag when generating
a cookie helps mitigate the risk of
client-side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the http only flag is
included in the http response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through the
client side script again this is if the
browser supports the slack
as a result even if a cross site
scripting flaw exists and a user
accidentally accesses a link that
exploits this flaw the browser will not
reveal the cookie to a third party
if a browser does not support http only
and a website attempts to set an http
only cookie the http only flag will be
ignored browser browser thus creating a
traditional script accessible cookie as
a result the cookie becomes vulnerable
to theft of modification by any
malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross site scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the top most
level sex
we are going to start at level 1.
in this verb application it demonstrates
the common cause of cross-slide
scripting where user input is directly
included in the page without proper
escaping
if we interact with a vulnerable
application window here and find a way
to make it execute javascript of our
choosing
we can take actions inside the
vulnerable window or directly edit its
url bar
this task needs only basic knowledge
let's see why the most primitive
injections work here right away
let's do a simple query and inspect the
resulting html page
i'm going to use this
phrase
with a single quote as a special
character
we can now inspect the html page
we can see here in this line
the special character single quote
appears in the result over here
the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the
payload should be included in the url to
perform successful exploitation
we can use any payload but we're going
to use the simple one to perform an
alert in this web application it's
simple and can be shown easily
i'm just going to write the script over
here
and we're going to press search
as you can see we have successfully
launched our first cross site scripting
attack
we can see an alert box pop-up with the
necessary message and a similar process
can be used to steal browser cookies and
passwords albeit with different commands
now we have the option to move to level
2.
in this web application it shows that
how easily xss bugs can be introduced in
complex chat applications
chat app conversations are stored in a
database and retrieved when a user wants
to see the conversation therefore if a
malicious user injects some javascript
code all visitors will be infected
this kind of cross-site scripting attack
is more powerful
and it is more riskier than reflected
cross-site scripting attacks and that's
why is known as stored xss
i posted my query
with a special character of a single
quote
and this is what i
get whatever i typed in simply appeared
on the page right after i click on share
status
let's see the source
you can see here the text i posted seems
directly put inside a block code tag so
even a simple script tag we used in
level 1 should work here
but it will not
let us examine the code to understand
why
we're going to toggle the code of a here
and check the index.html file
important part
is line 32.
the generated html fragment which is the
html variable in the code is added to
the mail html using the inner html
method so in the browser passing this
html fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that html
fragment
html parser will not execute a script
tag when it passes htmls via this method
this is why the script tag like we used
in level 1 is not going to work here our
solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
javascripts
we're going to use an image over here
and when we press on share status
above injection we are loading an image
that doesn't exist which causes to
trigger an on error event
in on error event
the it will execute our alert method
with that we are able to beat level 2
and we can now move up to the next level
in our challenge
as you can see
clicking on any tab causes the tab
number to be displayed in the url
fragment
this hints that the value after the
hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable
to confirm let's analyze the code
as you can see in line 43 inside the
event handling
the value provided after the hash in the
url
is directly passed on to the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed
the value passed to the choose tab
method is directly injected into the img
tag in line 17.
this is an unsafe assignment and it is
the vulnerable part of the code
now all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the img tag to
execute our javascript remember the
script tag from level 1 would not work
here since the variable html is used to
add the dom dynamically hence the events
are asus here once again
i will choose to use the existing img
tag and change the source to something
that doesn't exist
hence forcing it to fall in to execute
an on error even which i will pass the
url
once we visit that url we can see that
our java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed
with this we can now move on to level 4
which is going to present a different
kind of attack
in this web application there is a timer
on the page that means whatever numbers
we put in the box a countdown starts
and then when it finishes the
application alerts
that the countdown is finished
and we can see the time is up up
appearing over here and this resets the
timer again
now it is obvious that the value entered
in the text box is transferred to the
server over the timer parameter in the
url
let us examine the code to see how the
timer parameter is being handled
we're going to visit timer.html over
here
and we're going to check over here
in line 21
the start timer method is being called
in the onload event
however the timer parameter is being
directly passed to the start timer
method
we need to perform a pop-up alert in the
web application which escapes the
content of the function start timer
without breaking the javascript code
the parameter value is directly added
the start timer method without any
filtering
what we can try to do here is to inject
an alert function to be executed inside
the online event along with the start
timer method
we're going to remove this argument
and put a script over here
now i may press on create timer
and we have a pop-up with xss level 4
completed
we can now move on to level 5.
in this web application this application
xss is different because this challenge
description says cross-site scripting
isn't just about correctly escaping data
sometimes attackers can do bad things
even without injecting new elements into
the dom it's kind of open redirect
because the attack payload is executed
as a result of modifying the dom
environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client-side script so that the
client-side code runs in an unexpected
manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next link in the signup page
is inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confirm which is exactly the value of
the next url query parameter
as you can see over here
this means using the next query
parameter can be used to inject a
javascript code to the href attribute of
the next link
the following is the best way to do it
as soon as the user clicks on the link
the script will be triggered
we're going to press anything random
and now that we click next we can see
the xss level 5 that we had provided in
the url as a parameter to the next
variable
since the value of next provided appears
on a pop-up we can consider the attack
as success and move on to the final
level 6.
in this web application it shows some of
the external javascript is received
if you analyze the url
you can see that the script is loaded
already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the hashtag
if you check on line 45 the value right
after the hashtag
is taken as the gadget name
and then in line 48
the value is directly passed on to the
include gadget method another include
gadget method that we can see over here
you can see in line 18
a script tag is created and the url
gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line 28.
this means we can completely control the
source attribute of the script tag that
is being created
that is with this vulnerability we can
inject our own javascript file into the
code
we can inject a url of our own hosted
javascript into the web applications url
after the hashtag and the url should not
be using https but anything like that to
bypass the regular expression for
security checking
going to remove
the pre-stored url
and we're going to load our own
javascript file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge
completed six different varieties of
cross scripting attacks and use
different solutions for all of the six
questions
hope you learned something new today if
you have any questions regarding the
topic feel free to ask us in the
comments below and we will get back to
you as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
informative videos and thank you for
watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here